the green ocean turtle is facing
extinction it's made of to the Galapagos
Islands for the time being its natural
habitat is intact but scientists from
the Charles Darwin foundation have
observed a gradual change global warming
is affecting mating habits like here on
the island of Isabella Gustavo Jimenez
has been researching the galapagos
penguin for years it's the only pain
when that's native to the northern
hemisphere survey IL Conte oh we've
noticed a dramatic drop in penguin and
cormorant numbers we've seen a loss of
one third of the population tan fuerte
que es como la tercera parte
human factors are also affecting
wildlife the population of the Galapagos
Islands has risen tenfold in the last 30
years to 30,000 that adds to the
difficulty of preserving the local
biodiversity not long ago local wildlife
had the island of Floreana to themselves
today 127 people live here and they're
joined by several thousand tourists
every year in 2010 the islands energy
supply was revamped with financial
support from the international climate
initiative from Germany the generators
used here are now powered by biofuel
rather than diesel enrica Hyneman from
the German Agency for International
Cooperation remembers how things used to
be the scarp he of the endzone this
place used to only have power for just
four hours a day diesel fuel was
transported in tanks in metal barrels
and then pumped into dilapidated tanks
at the port leaked and the diesel was a
serious polluter lettuce cup and diesel
our scofflaw Sinise in your vote the
coastal region of Manabi is one of the
poorest in the world these days local
farmers are harvesting jatropha curcas
destined for the galapagos islands
previously they didn't bother it can't
be used as food because its seeds or
poisonous they were trained by Georg
rubas a German expert in biofuel demote
worn a scallop the engines here in the
galapagos islands are very modern have
to meet very strict emission standards
the quality of the fuel has to be very
high and Manabi is in a position to
supply this high quality Dietzen tried
to listen
this highly modern oil press is now
owned by a farmers collective more
generators on Isabella are in the
pipeline and the plan is to use bio fuel
to generate power on other Galapagos
Islands too Ecuador's government wants
to see an end to fossil fuels on the
Galapagos Islands it's a goal that will
take some time to achieve but experts
are determined to ensure the island's
biodiversity preserved it's too valuable
to lose like the green ocean turtle
you
you
you